so we're going on to one of the
respiratory Wards Jody and Nikki have
one of the most important jobs in
Coventry Hospital
and actively find patients that would be
suitable to go home as a part of an
early supportive discharge Ward's here
are nearly always full
so freeing up bed space is crucial
hospitals are very busy it's it's no um
it's not a hidden secret so you know if
we free up beds on our Wards then we
free up under the bed for someone else
that needs a bed the nurses have a short
list of potential patients the patient
they've identified is a man in his 50s
he's here because he has a long-term
lung condition he's typical of the sort
of patient that would benefit from being
cared for at home and crucially it means
for the hospital they have a bed free
for somebody else
hi Richard
yes are you all right Richard has a
chronic long-term lung condition he was
admitted last week that is desperate to
go home it's coming up to create Smurfs
it's really all my heating and
everything's on in my flats as well so
I'm burning electric at the minute
um I need to get home and sort things
out for Christmas really so yeah it
means everything to me Richard will
become a patient on a virtual Ward his
health will be monitored remotely by
staff at the hospital the shortage of
beds puts pressure on every part of the
hospital including its emergency
department this gives us a snapshot of
the scale of the demand on emergency
services so right now outside the a e we
have 10 ambulances waiting the longest
ambulance has been waiting just over
three hours now across the region
that has 436 patients who require an
ambulance
73 in our local area and we can see the
wait times just on there some people
have been waiting a very long time if
beds can't be found ambulances can't
hand over sick patients five years ago
you wouldn't you wouldn't come to
emergency departments be seen need a bed
and then wait several hours for that bed
that wouldn't happen we would have
considered that to be unacceptable and
that's now a daily occurrence
it was here exactly two years ago that
the world's first covered vaccine was
administered it changed the course of
the pandemic
that Health crisis also forced change on
the NHS like the virtual Ward that will
now let Richard go home early
our Health Service will need more
Innovation if it's to cope with a winter
that's coming
Ashish Josh is Sky News in Coventry